it's nice to see you
hello hello we did an interview together
the other day and I don't remember your
hair looking this fabulous I think it
was wearing a hat maybe okay I don't
know I'm like I love the longer look too
long is it you're gonna cut it I don't
know don't do it well it looks so cool
you've got the natural curl thing going
it's cool well thanks just saying I just
get frustrated having to do it in the
morning says every woman on the planet
join us
um I didn't make any resolutions I but I
I have a few things on my mind goals and
Ambitions yeah I feel like with the
resolutions it's kind of like set up for
for failure every time so I just kind of
approached it with some some personal
goals and professional goals yeah
um you know there's a lot on the person
front obviously being a new father yeah
so that's taking up
you're gonna try most of my time this
year exactly yeah I was like There's No
Sleep your daughter turned one right
though right um or she's about to turn
one she did yeah yeah well over the over
the weekend okay over the weekend okay
she's there a big party we did yeah yeah
a little you know he had to celebrate
she went through a pretty wild journey
in the early part of her life
um and so we we had to celebrate in
style yeah she's uh she's one she's
beautiful it's amazing she's adorable
yeah oh my gosh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]